there's a lot that goes into moviemaking
especially huge productions like the
Marvel Studios mega blockbuster Avengers
infinity war between principal
photography adding CGI effects and
reshoots scheduling can become a
mind-bogglingly complex equation often
Studios like Marvel have to begin
editing before they've even finished
filming the movie so it's no wonder that
mistakes start to creep in and despite
how awesome Avengers infinity war is
even the biggest blockbuster event of
the year is an immune to editing
mistakes as one eagle-eyed Marvel fan
discovered when he found a glaring
continuity error that somehow completely
slipped past everyone at Marvel Studios
what is this huge mistake well during
the climactic battle at the end of the
film fan OHS has shown grabbing vision
by the throat on two separate occasions
everything you ever knew is a lie okay
so maybe it's not that big a deal in
fact you probably didn't even notice it
when you were watching Avengers infinity
war in the theater but once the mistake
was pointed out by Reddit user for AJ in
a handy graphic it's pretty hard to miss
the scene in question takes place just
after Scarlet Witch uses her hex power
to destroy visions mind stone preventing
Thanos from completing the Infinity
Gauntlet and destroying half the life in
the universe
unfortunately Thanos uses the time stone
to rewind history and once vision is
alive again he grabs the synthezoid by
the throat when Scarlet Witch tries to
intervene
Thanos clobbers her after she hits the
ground the camera pans back over to
Thanos and vision and Thanos has shown
reaching for visions throat even though
he just had his big meaty villain hand
around it a few seconds before Thanos
then lifts vision off the ground holds
him in the air by his throat and scoops
out the mine stone we know that OSes
whole thing is taking tyranny to the
extreme and being as over-the-top as
possible not quite as dramatic as the
late Loki but pretty close but a double
chokehold seems a bit excessive though
it's definitely detectable and certainly
won't go unnoticed now that it's made
the rounds on the internet this mistake
doesn't really affect the overall
quality of the movie at all even after
learning Fanus grabs vision by the
throat twice in the span of a few
seconds every Marvel fan would likely
say that Avengers infinity war is still
as
impact at times hilarious and ultimately
heart-wrenching as it was before anyone
noticed that small editing mistake and
more than that this certainly isn't the
first time a Marvel Cinematic Universe
installment has featured an error or at
least a perceived error in spider-man
homecoming for instance a graphic stated
that the film took place eight years
after the events of the first Avengers
movie when it should have only been five
and remember the mysterious case of
Bucky Barnes is changing birthday his
birth year has been variously listed as
1916 1917 and 1922 and there was the car
dent that fixed itself in the Avengers
the money that magically flew out of a
wallet and the Incredible Hulk and the
disappearing head set in Iron Man and
huh we could go on and on but why
nitpicks some of our favorite films if
anything these little harmless goof ups
are just reassuring proof that while the
Avengers may be superhuman the folks at
Marvel who make these great films are
just normal people like the rest of us
people who sometimes make mistakes and
sometimes make great movies it just
makes us more excited than ever to find
out what happens in Avengers 4 which is
scheduled to arrive in theaters in may
20 19 will the Dead return to life will
the Avengers prevail will Thanos choke
vision a third time whatever happens we
can't wait to find out
[Music]